boa noite
é um prazer estar aqui com vocês hoje
bom eu vou me apresentar rapidinho eu
quero saber rapidinho só aqui na platéia
quem aqui acha que é criativo e quem
acha que é um visionário duas pessoas
bom conta rapidinho eu eu sou
publicitário eu estudei artes gráficas
na austrália sofreu
formado em pós-graduação em curadoria
coleccionismo eu trabalho tenho uma
revista de arte chama sup e os o curador
do festival pixel show também que foi a
realização minha que já tem 15 anos de
vida
eu a partir desse slide não vou mostrar
mais falta nenhuma o que eu venho trazer
aqui pra vocês hoje é falar um pouco
sobre esquecer um pouco do digital age
pensar um pouco no ser humano
eu vou contar um pouco sobre trajetórias
sobre a inspiração que pra mim acho que
não só pra mim mas o que eu quero tentar
passar para vocês aqui como a gente
busca o nosso ócio criativo sobre as
nossas ideias é um sonho por exemplo o
que eu passei eu tenho tempo eu quero
tentar compartilhar essas idéias com
vocês eu quero que vocês também aprendo
um pouco comigo com o que eu aprendi com
outras pessoas que eu confio que eu me
inspiro e eu espero que eu consiga
passar um pouquinho dessas coisas que eu
tive nos últimos anos meu passado é
então vamos começar aqui falando sobre o
ócio criativo é o que é
a gente precisa de um tempo por exemplo
todo mundo trabalha aqui que nem um
maluco fica no celular fica digital
instagram a tap admite tarde do dia em
vez de trabalhar lá mexendo num no
computador ou no instagram respondendo a
algum amigo respondendo e mail
o que a gente precisa principalmente
trabalhando com criatividade é um pouco
de ócio então
é de nuno pinto fechou a pixel show
nosso personagem principal é o bicho
preguiça e nada mais é o cara que mais
descansa tá sempre sonhando imaginando
coisas e eu sou um pouco bicho-preguiça
eu desde pequeno sempre fui sonhador é o
meu sócio que o simon
ele é o âncora brinca muito que eu sou o
photoshop é o excel do negócio ea gente
basicamente pra gente discute muito
assim mas a gente fala assim tanto os
nossos funcionários nossa equipe por
exemplo pixel show tem 150 pessoas
abaixo da gente é um evento que
praticamente a gente está trabalhando a
gente começa a trabalhar é o evento
agora em novembro final de novembro
dezembro então no dia seguinte a gente
já está também na verdade já está
trabalhando em um plano que o seguinte
nos próprios próximos anos
então a gente precisa usar o ócio
criativo um pouco pra gente está
pensando em 10 os sonhos como que a
gente vai conseguir pegar os nossos
sonhos e transformar a eles em realidade
então a gente trabalha muito e é a arte
economia criativa então mas 360 graus o
que a gente busca é tentar inspirar é
registrar e mostrar e trabalhos autorais
e tentar colocar isso nas pessoas que
todo mundo gosta de fazer alguma coisa
não simplesmente então a gente vai falar
aqui sobre eu vou falar sobre três
palavras vão passar um pouquinho que eu
trouxe pra vocês não sei eu sou judeu
então eu trouxe um pouco de hebraico
aqui eu não falei com algumas coisas mas
tem coisas que eu aprendi na minha vida
então vou falar um pouco sobre a palavra
mazza que significa sorte
não sei se alguém tem algum amigo judeu
já foi um casamento judaico já famosa
tov neto é começa a levantar os caras na
cadeira é dança que nem um maluco mas é
isso que a gente quer falar pra gente
chegar num nível de felicidade é
trabalhar e se divertir e aproveitar
cada momento da nossa vida
então ele fala mas há também fala com
você tem sucesso eu tenho um time mais
ao meu negócio não ser humano na minha
tarefa que estava fazendo
cavanagh quem tem são o foco então acho
que não só aqui mas as outras pessoas
também tem muita gente falando sobre
isso mas sua expulsão a origem tem mais
cinco mil anos de história isso essas
palavras então fala sobre um pouco de
intenção em foco ea palavra si bak a
propósito tá então vou começar a falar
um pouco de edições vida sempre passar o
nosso background em direção às lições de
vida a gente pode não pode esquecer a
gente tem que pensar no futuro mas a
gente não pode esquecer do nosso passado
enquanto a gente está fazendo as coisas
no dia de hoje
então basicamente é eu comecei era
pequena meus pais foram me incentivando
e fazer escola de esportes nos pais me
levavam muito em galerias o que foi
muito importante porque na mesma escola
e não sei como ficou uma como é aqui mas
em são paulo
todo ano a gente tinha no sete de
setembro no museu do ipiranga
tanto por mas não tinha outros museus
sabe que na minha infância que eu podia
ter iv e visitados em galerias ou uma
ópera não sei
então meus pais fazer nossa parte
cultural comigo então a gente ano no
cinema em uma obra no teatro então isso
foi começando a fazer repertório ao
mesmo tempo paralelo
eu fui fazendo escola de artes o que
óbvio que foi meu pinpoo caminhando e
mudando um pouco do que eu sou
depois disso passou muito tempo com um
eu tinha 13 anos eu ganhei em um
computador que 1 286 bilhão a monitor
vez de fósforo e eu chegava da escola
fica o dia inteiro jogando joguinho em
um dia a gente apronta alguma coisa o
meu irmão meu irmão não só sei que eu
sinto que eu falei antes a gente não
aquela bronca ficou olhando e depois de
castigo olhando para a cara do outro e
nossos pais simplesmente falando assim
hoje vocês fazem alguma coisa útil com
esse computador ou a gente vai descartar
ele então pra vocês focarem nas tarefas
que são importantes que a estudar
aí acho que ficou assim abismado assim
na época do outro por meia hora sem
falar nada e aí o senhor chegou pra mim
o que gosta de desenhar é que a gente
vai fazer o último com um computador
você gosta de desenhar e você
olhar pra cara do cinema falou não não
sei o que você gosta
ele era sempre foi mais alto que eu
tenho um metro e 92 eu tenho mais de 70
ele sempre foi um cara sério é o cara
mais brincalhão ea gente fala então eu
vou desenhar então o que eu sei fazer
você vai vender as minhas coisas então
foi melhor que assim que começou a
história a gente criou opa está
funcionando aqui o que criou uma empresa
chamada hakkar desemprego e chegou ao
nosso país e pediu hoje que a 300 reais
que na época ela cruzeiros cruzados não
lembro mas não se pode ficar olhando
achar engraçado e deram pra gente
falando que esses moleques vão aprontar
com 300 reais
então no fundo a gente meio que já quem
sabe eu quero empreendedorismo a gente
foi lá que começou molequinho uma
brincadeira de empreendedor sem saber o
significado dessa palavra
a gente três meses depois apresentou com
profundo hoje passa por fora montou todo
todo o material a gente apresentou pra
eles
a lei busca era simplesmente uma empresa
que fazia teta e cartões
cartão-de-visita logotipo esse tipo de
material
nosso primeiro cliente óbvio minha mãe
olhou por forma a falar eu quero te
disse que tinha pra fechar a carta para
mandar pro festa de boas festas
foram perfeitos aquecem recente que
ganhar 10 reais
pouco tempo depois meu avô
meus tios meus primos os filhos irmãos
amigos e quando a gente viu um ano
depois estava em um monte de gente
conhecida
e a gente já tinha comprado dois
computadores 4 e também com monitor
colorido ea gente ficava jogando
joguinho da tarde inteira
só que aí fazendo alguma coisa útil e aí
a gente começa a descobrir que era legal
tipo a gente trabalha e estuda faz
coisas que gosta de jogar bola e
continua foi e já está fazendo alguma
coisa que a gente sem saber o futuro é o
que a gente faria no futuro
então aí como é que as coisas começam a
mudar a gente vem uma bifurcação algum
acidente de percurso
eu fiz curso de robótica nada a ver com
que eu depois que eu fui fazer
comunicação em 1996 além em cima e
separou
no bis nénão na vida cada um foi para um
lado eu fui fazer propaganda e marketing
e ele
dois anos depois foi fazer administração
que no fundo é o excel e photoshop
depois de dez anos e se encontrou de
novo eu já tinha criado em 2001 azul pe
em 2006 ele compra a parte da empresa ea
gente começa a trabalhar junto então e
cada um fazendo exatamente o que fazia
no passado quer dizer leigos a gente o
que a gente fala eu tentei me juntar com
um pouco da minha história sobre a
palavra mas a oea me significa uma com
que é lugar
os edis mano que é tempo e ldl mude que
é conhecimento de que é este tipo a
gente vai fazendo as nossas coisas mas a
gente tem que fazer porque a gente gosta
e não porque a gente tem tesão sabe não
porque a gente está pensando em ganhar
dinheiro é só fazer uma tarefa por fazer
porque a gente precisa de emprego sabe
então a gente meio que esse encontro foi
um negócio meio nosso primeiro mazão
assim a gente sem saber por que eu
estava procurando um sócio mas sem
querer
o simon estava mesmo satisfeito com o
comércio exterior quantas empresas
grandes que ele trabalhava ea gente
começou a conversar eu tava precisando
de ajuda precisa de mais pessoas para
captar pra conseguir fazer minhas ideias
projectos e flamengo
eu vou começar a fazer devagarzinho aqui
e se der certo largo peço demissão e
foco 100% na azul pe
então a gente fala espanhol estava no
lugar certo no tempo certo ea gente
chegou a ter o conhecimento cercaram com
seu estudo
cada um no seu lugar ea gente se
encontrou e começou a fazer um ano
depois a minha sul cresceu 4 50% não foi
bom assim
a gente comprou um imóvel comprar nossa
sede
normalmente o ideal seria lugar a mãe
fala tão barato em 2008 isso metro
quadrado era barato ainda então ele
começou a fazer
se juntando e comecei a fazer novos
projetos
aí o time entrou cultura o conhecimento
erê incentivo cultural projeto cultural
como fazer como conseguir captação de
marcas de empresas governo e assim por
diante
é claro que nada são só flores neto que
a gente tem muitos desafios sempre tem
nunca vai parar de ter diversas
dificuldades então aí o que há entre a
palavra é a cavanagh tipo a gente tem
que a gente tem que ter aquela não pode
desistir nunca a gente tem assim valeu
até brinco que no começo da azul que eu
falava meu que me matando tem que pagar
contas o que acho que eu vou desistir
afirma uma pastelaria que a feira está
sempre cheia de gente e eu pelo menos
não vou conseguir lá pagar pagar minha
conta de luz paga silva no cinema mas
nem imagina ficar eu tenho várias idéias
para minutos que eu penso em dez
projetos não fazer
ainda há tempo nem para pensar que já
pensa em outra imagem ele trabalhava
ficava fazendo papel né
então imagina se deixar o seu sonho de
lado pra você focar em uma coisa que era
oo principal é o cifrão sofrendo não
posso fazer isso que eu sou totalmente
contra sempre falei que ia fazer o que
fazer uma coisa que você gosta
um projeto do sonho e transformar isso
em realidade
então aí começa a entrar com aquela
prova campeonato a gente não desistiu e
se focar no que a gente quer é e meu
planejar fazer modelos de negócio e
atrás conversar com as pessoas fazer
networking e é com isso que a gente vai
conseguir enfrentar as dificuldades os
desafios e fazer um negócio dar certo
então quando eu dizia era pastelaria um
simão entrando na empresa é um negócio
começou a fazer o desing cana que o
dinheiro uma hora vai vim mas tem q tem
q quando vem o dinheiro tem que ser
porque está fazendo uma coisa que você
realmente gosta
eu vou falar rapidinho aqui porque eu
coloquei isso aqui a gente tem diversos
pontos de vistas néné é a gente tem um
lado negro da força né
é o lado bom que seja da força
só que isso é muito por exemplo o lado
bom
acha que o lado negro está errado que
não podem fazer tem um é ético não tem
os objetivos são diferentes mas o lado
negro acha que quem está errado é um
lado bom no lado positivo então negativa
no ano positivo
o que a gente porque eu acho assim é
óbvio que o lado negro da força assim
pra trás um pouco falei acho que ela
consegue tudo mais fácil não só aqui mas
qual é a graça de fazer uma coisa que é
fácil né tipo então por exemplo se as
coisas caem do céu você vai lembrar o
passado lá foi tão fácil consegui
eu comecei a empresa tinha 10 milhões de
investimento e negócio foi super rápido
então eu comecei do zero
eu coloquei no meu dinheiro viria de
real e real e conseguir fazer um negócio
então e no futuro vai conseguindo os
investidores vão chegando então a gente
fala assim é negativo mas negativo é bem
diferente de positivo está o que isso
significa sim pra mim eu vim pra vocês
então a gente tem que fazer as coisas
que a gente curte pensar tentar sempre
pensar positivo que nem sempre é fácil
na cultura que acontece em nossas nossas
lindas governos é todo dia mudar uma
regra então você tá fazendo negócio
andana mudou a regra tem que ir pro
desviar andando em uma pedra no sapato
vai pro lado
então toda hora acontece alguma coisa
ele tem que ficar pensando em como
resolver soluções uma atrás da outra uma
atrás da outra então é mesmo tempo a
gente tem que ser criativo e tudo isso
tem interligado uma grande consciência
criativa então é ao mesmo tempo que está
fazendo aquela parte pinça em ócio
criativo
a gente colocou nem está no nosso sim
uma rede lendo um livro
o ócio é um pouco dessa grande
plataforma mais fundas a gente pensar
para desligado do mundo desligado o que
a gente está fazendo esse estresse podem
parar e focar em uma coisa vou focar
numa história que é um livro eu vou
agora desligar o celular e conversar com
minha família e e tudo isso vai juntando
ele vai começar a falar eu vou deixando
o que é negativo que é estressante de
lado e vai começar a focar no positivo
então a gente volta aqui pro a última
palavra o siba e tem três basicamente
três tipos de profissionais tem aquele
profissional que faz só o trabalho e que
vai pra casa mas é isso ele não pensa em
mais nada
tem um profissional que quer fazer uma
carreira então o cara se mata mas o
objetivo dele é xavier diretor é um
salário mas não é exatamente o que o
cara gosta e tem o profissional quem é o
que eu acho que eu espero que todo mundo
aqui tem início depois que o
profissional que faz que tem um
propósito que eu queria ter uma idéia
tem uma coisa que goste de fazer um
sonho e que você vai focar nisso vai
batalhar favor de tudo o que os outros
fazem
só que de coração é tentando falar não é
isso é uma ideia eu quero fazer
então eu me esforçava toda a dificuldade
que eu tiver vou até o final ou
planejava fazer um modelo de negócio
achar as pessoas certas que vão estar me
ajudando no meio do caminho que é o
networking e mesmo quando você está
naquele domingo no inconsciente
a gente não começar a pensar sempre no
futuro então e o futuro que quer o
futuro é a felicidade
a gente tem que fazer se a gente faz uma
coisa que a gente gosta não que a gente
tem foco a gente lida com stress têm
mais fundas faz coisas que gosta então
se você não tem não vai ter depressão
provavelmente porque você vai fazendo
sempre que gosta das coisas do dia de
hoje nas doenças atuais
então a gente pode falar que a ciência
de que a nossa consciência
vai tudo isso juntando a gente vai
conseguir chegar à felicidade que a
satisfação pessoal então fazer o que
gosta de coração então interessa nada
que esteja se possui um design pode ser
um ator pode ser um jornalista um
arquiteto não interessa pois é um cara
que tá vendendo é bom né
na fila na rua com o ambulante mas se o
cara gosta de fazer isso ele vai ser
feliz
então basicamente é isso que eu tenho
que falar pra vocês hoje mas e agora
vocês têm que compartilhar esse quantas
pessoas que nem estou fazendo agora com
vocês mas quanto mais gente fazer o que
gosta
a gente vai chegar nisso aqui de novo
nessa situação nessa consciência
criativa chegar à felicidade e pé isso
networking
então obrigado e vamos compartilhar essa
ideia pessoal
[Aplausos]